now things are changing for your project
and for Andy's too got Andy on speed
dial number four hey Andy can you come
down to my desk for a sec great thanks
now the project manager has changed the
requirements in two different ways first
of all there's not one cat anymore now
there are two cats
second of all the cat name should be
above the cat image so how you implement
that is completely up to you but I would
recommend avoiding the most naive of
solutions don't just hard code the cat
name and the Dom or in the documents
instead store that in a JavaScript
variable and then update the document
hey Andy hey what's up so the project
requirements have changed okay cat
clicker dual let me guess
- cats - cats can you do it I didn't
plan for that but I think I could
probably figure it out awesome